- I feel like that's what it's
like being a woman anyways.
Like half the time,
it's like I feel great,
not gonna lie.
So I work with a buncha men, right?
I literally am the only
female that travels
with about 30 guys when I do NFL games,
and sometimes you're workin' a game
when your ovaries are hurting, right?
- It's a great, I love being a girl,
let's celebrate International Girl's Day.
(applause)
It is fun, but did you
happen to hear Elizabeth?
- I did, where is she?
- Wasn't that amazing?
- Baller, 32 yard field goal, yes please.
And I'll be honest, there's some guys
in the NFL that would like hope
they make a 32 yard field goal,
and ya look hot.
- I know, I was like, and
she was homecoming queen!
- That's awesome.
- But anyway, how did you
become interested in sports?
I always ask my friends that.
- Yeah, cause of my dad, my
dad's a great storyteller,
he's on television, and he would tell me
all about players, and like
what players liked each other,
and what players didn't like each other,
and what coaches had been with what teams,
and he was just a good, good storyteller.
So I became a fan that way.
- A teacher, really.
- Yeah, and so, I decided at an early age
I was gonna do it for a living.
- That's a really cool thing.
I just thought it's
something outta the ordinary.
- His favorite story is though,
not so much when I was like dad,
hey Larry Bird and Magic
Johnson and Kevin McHale,
his favorite was when I was in the aisle
of the grocery store and I
was like dad, what's that?
And it's like a tampon, you know,
and he's like, well
let's have mom tell you
when we get home.
- You know what, I'm gonna
cover sports, she's got that.
(laughs)
So what advice do you have
for girls tryin' to, you know,
break into a male dominated field?
- Yeah, I mean, I think no matter
if you're tryin' to be
a sports broadcaster
or you're tryin' to do anything else,
which really seems all male
dominated at this point,
I just say work really hard.
And another one, which I mean
I know you and I can relate to,
is have thick skin.
Which, I'm still tryin' to work on,
but the unfortunate part,
and Kelly knows this
about being in the public eye,
is everybody has an opinion,
and they can say it,
and they can post it on your Instagram,
and they can be livin' with
their mom at 50 years old
in their mom's basement and
still have a fun opinion.
It's taken me a long time
to try to have thick skin,
I think I'm really doing
a lot better about it
than I used to.
I feel like when you're in
your 20's and your 30's,
you're like okay, stop, you're
really hurting my feelings.
I'm in my 40's now, and
I'm like you know what,
like I'm not doing it for you anyways.
So, still workin' on it.
- That's the thing, yeah,
you should do it for you.
Tell us about your new project,
I wanna hear about your new project.
- Yes, so, huge sports fan obviously, and
- I can get into this
part of sports world.
- Yeah, you can, I'm just somebody that,
like let's be honest,
I'm not a fashion icon,
I'm more of a tomboy, I
like to be comfortable.
I mean that's just my jam.
I wear a ballroom gown on
Dancing with the Stars,
I wear comfortable
clothes on the sidelines,
something in between.
But I felt like there
was a real white space
in the team apparel area for women.
I just felt like women
weren't being catered to,
there weren't many options out there,
and I'm a diehard fan,
but I don't need the team logo
splattered across my chest.
Just a fun, fashionable way
to kinda cheer for your team.
And then I just felt like sizes
are very hard to deal with,
we're excited cause we
have a ton of sizes.
Yes, absolutely, and who by
the way, wants, you know,
to feel uncomfortable?
You wanna be feeling great, looking great,
and cheering for your
team at the same time.
In sports, my nickname is EA, so you know,
throw down in the field and EA is there,
so we created a line called
WEAR, spelled it with the EA,
and our slogan is you can wear
it anywhere and everywhere.
- Well, audience members Veronica
and Jenny are representing
our two teams here in LA,
ladies can you stand up?
There ya go.
Look how cute you are.
Let's talk about love, cause
you just got married, right?
- Two years ago.
(cheers)
- That's still puppy love.
- Is it?
- Yeah, what's the newlywed situation?
Look at you.
Aw, those who workout
together stay together.
- Yeah, so he's a retired hockey player,
I don't know how to skate whatsoever,
so basically I'm saying
there's a camera on me,
if you let go of me, I will kill you.
His family was all there
waiting for me to eat it,
but it was fine.
- Do you love marriage though, is it good?
- Yeah, it's fine, I mean
we don't see each other, so.
(laughs)
It seems like it's working out just fine.
I mean, right now with my
schedule with football,
and he's working with
the Los Angeles Kings,
yeah, we're kind of out.
The only thing we really
discuss too much is
when is our, did our
dog go to the bathroom?
And I know you have kids,
we're working on it,
but it's like, right now
with a dog, it's like,
you've never talked more about
poop in your entire life.
It's like did he poop today?
Oh, he didn't poop today, well
is he gonna poop tomorrow?
I mean, I better text my mom
and ask if it's a big deal.
- It is worse when it's the children,
cause especially boys, you
walk in and you're like,
oh you played in it.
That's awesome.
Cool, it's in every crevice of your crib,
probably in your mouth.
And then you just cry, Erin, you just cry.
- So I'll take that back,
we're not gonna have kids.
I'm fine with just Howard.
- All right, switching gears from poo,
you were, no, this is
actually more serious,
and my family's been highly
affected by cervical cancer,
and you were actually
diagnosed in 2016, right?
So, I guess my question
is, you're fine now right?
- Fine right now.
- And how did you find out?
- Just honestly, thank you,
just from a regular annual exam.
I mean, right before I go to
football season every year,
it's like going back to school
when your mom would like
get your teeth checked,
now it's like go to the
doctor, go to the gyno,
get the extensions done, get
the roots done, all that.
And I, literally yeah, week
three of the football season
that year, got a text.
And you know when you
get a text from your gyno
on a Saturday it's not good.
So, yeah, wheel's went into motion,
and ended up having two
cervical cancer surgeries.
There was a little bit of a concern
that I was gonna have
to have a hysterectomy,
but I did not have to
have that, thank god.
- I had that happen with a friend,
and I always tell all
my friends, I'm like,
get your eggs first before you do it,
because after radiation, you know.
- Oh yeah, and that
was a big thing for us,
like, before we had the second surgery
when the first one didn't work,
there was a big conversation we did.
We've done all that stuff,
but you have to, you have to make sure.
- Some doctors don't mention that
because they're so
concerned about the cancer.
Obviously we're concerned
about the patient,
but that's an important
thing for women and men
that want children.
- Yeah, and even more
important, I mean again,
there's no symptoms with
cervical cancer, I was fine.
And I remember when we first
got the test results back,
I remember telling some of my friends
and they were like, you're
fine, you work out all the time,
you eat right, you're in great shape,
and I was like, it has
nothing to do with that.
- That was literally my next point,
and I was gonna say, you're
like the picture of health,
and it can happen to anyone,
and you really should
get regular checkups.
- And again, because there
aren't any symptoms of it,
and I just found it on an annual exam,
and even worse, not to scare everybody
and get them on Web MD right now,
but I was going every single year.
So it's not like I was
somebody that missed my annual,
I was going every single year.
Then I had friends, after I came out
and I revealed that I had had it,
said oh my god I haven't
been in three years,
and I'm like, would you, you
need to go to the doctor.
Like you just have to go and get checked,
because much like prostate
cancer which my dad had,
you should not die of cervical cancer.
It's curable and it is detectable,
and you just need to go to the doctor.
- But the reason why
the rate is so alarming
with ovarian and cervical cancer is
because you don't know you have it.
So by the time you know you have it,
you might be at stage four.
Yeah, so that's why it's so deadly.
- So after this, call your doctor,
go get your checkup.
- Get in those stirrups, ladies.
(applause)
- I mean, I am so
thankful for my oncologist
and everything, and he
is such a wonderful,
good-looking man, and I'm always so sad
that's how I see him every six months.
Because I do, I have to
go every six months now.
That's my checkup, it is horrible,
and then you go, and they
take your blood pressure,
and they're like your blood pressure's up,
and I'm like, well no crap.
I'm like waiting to get this test done.
Yeah, and then I leave, and
I got eat a big fat donut,
and I go shopping, I'm like whew!
- You deserve it at that point.
- Yeah, eat a pizza.
- Oh my god, I love pizza.
So, the new season of Dancing
with the Stars premiered,
and there's a new twist on
it, which I actually love.
- There is a twist, and I wonder
if y'all have this on your show.
Our judges can actually save a dancer,
which is really fun and exciting.
- On The Voice, we do have save.
It's my favorite part.
- Don't you feel that's so stressful?
- Yeah, and sometimes it's like,
I've been that contestant in that moment,
and it's like it all, it counts.
And sometimes you just have
a weird show or whatever,
people that usually love
you weren't home voting,
and it's like, well this person
does not deserve to go home.
So it gives you that chance,
you know, to save them.
- No, it's very exciting,
I'm glad I'm not that person,
because I just wanna save everyone.
But yeah, it's awesome.
That's why I love live TV so much,
cause anything can happen,
and it's like oh, what's gonna go on here?
- Juicy, yeah, I love
live TV too, I'm with you.
Well, be sure to catch Erin
on the sidelines for Fox
and on Dancing with the Stars,
Monday nights on ABC y'all.
- And get your WEAR!
- Get your WEAR, I'm gettin' my WEAR,
I'm gettin' that tracksuit.